[Music]
come on rick
we're almost there leave me morty it's
the only way
what were we are we blades in that one
that's tight
stay with me i'm i'm scared morty i can
see the end
oh god there's nothing i know i always
said that but oh god there's really
nothing i'm sorry morty
i'm a silly man i'm a silly small man i
wasted it all
i'm sorry i got you into this but how
about i get us
out of this
hello hey jessica it's morty from school
oh hey morty
what's up um i just want to say that
you're really great i know the timing
never really worked out with us but
you're really great and i wish i got to
know you better oh i mean
that's a lot oh uh yeah sorry i guess i
just no
i just wish you said it sooner what yeah
i mean
you never really said anything to me
which always put me in a weird position
because i didn't want to assume or
whatever being nervous is sort of
selfish sometimes you know
yeah that's a great point well what are
you doing tonight
tonight yeah do you like want to watch a
movie or something
um yeah tonight sounds great great see
you later morty
bye holy [ __ ] i want to live
[ __ ] death i want to live
[Music]
where where are we home right where we
belong no seriously morty where the [ __ ]
are we i don't i don't know
the ocean the ocean the ocean on earth
oh yeah
i guess so [ __ ] holy [ __ ] we have to go
we have to go right
now you touched the ocean morning oh
[ __ ]
what
richard you have desecrated the sacred
treaty betwixt land and
sea now face the wrath of your once and
eternal foe
mr nimbus sorry who the [ __ ] is that
my nemesis what my nemesis okay
okay but what was his name again i am mr
nimbus he's gonna say that a lot
[Music]
welcome back everyone happy comic-con
week this is gonna be my rick and morty
season 5 teaser trailer video they just
dropped this new clip it's supposed to
be a cold open from one of the episodes
dan harmon didn't say which episode
though so if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's going to be a bunch more
comic-con trailers this week
we're doing an amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite easter egg from
this clip on the video
whole lot of marvel easter eggs in here
too although you could say there are
some dc easter eggs with that tag scene
of mr nimbus
they talked about a lot of season five
and season six stuff during the
comic-con panel so i'll add that later
in the video too but we'll just start
with the easter eggs from the season
five teaser trailer
so it starts with rick and morty
escaping at the end of another adventure
remember this is supposed to be a cold
open so we don't know exactly what that
adventure was but everything has gone
wrong there's this giant space worm
that's coming out star wars style you
can look at that as an empire strikes
back easter egg
but what looks like happened here is
that something happened maybe with
rick's portal gun and there was some
giant explosion and now all these
different dimensions
are bleeding into one another like these
different shards represent
alternate realities and different
versions of rick and morty
the biggest call out the biggest easter
egg is obviously marvel's blade were we
blades in that one that's tight
morty's the only one that's dressed in
the full blade costume so maybe rick was
whistler in that one
but if you didn't recognize it or if you
haven't seen the first blade movie in a
while this is basically the opening
scene of the first blade movie where he
goes into the club with all the vampires
and takes them all down
since this is just an animatic not all
these are finished they'll get way more
polished and they'll be way more easter
eggs in the background during the final
version of the episode but you see morty
cradling a baby version of rick there
was a baby rick way back during season
three episode vii
i cloned myself as a baby so that you
could kiss me there's a woodcutter
lumberjack version of rick there's a
cool looking version of morty this just
seems like he's a total badass
then morty pilots them through one of
the closing windows back to their main
dimension
thinking that they're going to crash to
earth this is the end of it so of course
the last call that he's ever going
to make is going to be to jessica to
tell her he loves her but then it turns
into this whole big thing about how she
might like him but he never said
anything so morty's like screw that
i'm going to live and they crash in the
ocean then it turns into another big
thing with rick's quote unquote nemesis
that we're just finding out about now
rick has pissed off a ton of people
there are a ton of enemies that he's
created in previous seasons that are
still alive and could come back to bite
him in the ass
but the big joke here is that rick can't
go anywhere near the ocean
and if we're talking about comic book
marvel dc easter eggs
mr nimbus just resembles marvel's name
or a little bit more than he resembles
aquaman from the justice league
but because this is the cold open
usually cold opens don't have anything
to do
with the episodes that they're actually
at the beginning of so whatever episode
this shows up at the beginning of
the regular episode will be completely
different they answered a bunch of big
questions about what's going on with the
season five episodes in season six dan
harmon revealed that they're almost done
with the finale for season five they're
doing some touch-ups
on that so they might actually be able
to premiere most of the episodes or at
least the first half by the end of this
year
and if they don't do that and they
decide to hold all the episodes to
spring next year they might wind up
airing all
10 back-to-back instead of breaking them
in half so good news there but he did
reveal that they're also in the middle
of
writing season six episodes so there
were a lot of questions about characters
coming back
especially clone bet so because they've
written a lot of the season six episodes
he actually did have some answers about
who's coming back and who's not coming
back
right now as for the alternate version
of beth that we saw at the end of the
season he said that she doesn't come
back during season five but she does
come back during season six in a big way
so clone beth backed during season six
they also went on about a lot of clone
best stuff at the end of season four the
way they left things and what's going on
with rick do they actually know
inside the writers room which one is the
real beth and which one is the clone
the way dan harmon talked about it he
said that as writers he feels like they
don't know and they built that into the
show and that was all about rick's arc
rick not knowing during the episode this
is him talking about that he also talks
about how the writers are using rick's
character during that scene to make fun
of themselves for being bad writers
and that rick also upon finding out that
he
that he also made himself forget that he
doesn't know and when he found out he
doesn't know he said i'm
a terrible father which is a metaphor
for us saying we're bad writers
um but it's also like a very ancient
greek
thing where it's like zeus is atoning
with athena and going like
i don't this is how i create i create
through abuse
i don't i don't i like i i i have
created now
two women who are have been bifurcated
by my aggressive refusal to
um commit to anything and
if if that's not where the buck stops
and
if i don't now accept this then what
happens are there
is there an infinite beth you know
storyline that happens
harmon stop yes there is you've heard it
here
uh but in the meantime you have this
cool thing which is like
well you know everybody's gotta
everybody's got that crazy aunt that
comes in from nevada
i if memory serves we kind of blow it in
terms of addressing it in season five
but god damn season six
is uh there's some clone bath fireworks
so i know everybody has theories about
which one is the real beth and which one
is the clone beth but it sounds like
they don't have any plans to actually
answer that definitively
anytime soon but there might be some
clues during season six like i said dan
harmon implied that there be no clone
beth stuff
during season five he said that the
vindicators have not come back in season
five or season six yet but they could
come back in season seven
he said that there's no morty's mind
blowers episode during season five or
season six but maybe during season seven
they joked about maybe doing morty's
mind blowers three or interdimensional
cable three so it sounds like eventually
they'll do one of those episodes again
but like they did the story train
episode
at the beginning of season four so they
always do sort of gimmicky style
episodes like that they'll probably do
something a little bit different but
also in that same vein during season
five
one of the biggest family dynamic and
story changes that dan hartmann revealed
is that there's actually this subplot
now with
rick slowly becoming friends with jerry
even though he joked that that might be
the show
jumping the shark like that might break
the show if they actually become real
friends
the way they talked about it made it
sound a little bit like the whirly dirly
conspiracy episode if you remember the
way that ended
they found some common ground and ended
on a bit of a truce but then rick still
kind of threw him under the bus
like locked the door still let them out
in the cold so that's sort of the status
of their relationship right now
but dan harmon did reveal that rick
would not hurt jerry in any meaningful
way like he could do anything he wanted
to he could erase him from existence
he could permanently neuter him but
because of the family dynamic
he's agreed not to hurt jerry they made
a lot of jokes about matthew broderick's
talking cat coming back eventually
although dan harmon did say that he
doesn't come back during season five or
season six
everyone was just so fascinated with
that cat during the episode there were
so many theories about what was going on
with his character
and what they saw in his mind dan also
spent a lot of time
ripping on family guy they did talk
about big crossovers and if you're a
huge fan of bojack horseman
on netflix dan harmon actually did tease
in real life he actually hopes that they
do a bojack
crossover at some point not just joking
around like actually do a real crossover
with the show
and i know i mentioned a couple marvel
easter eggs during that season 5 teaser
trailer and that animatic scene
but if you guys didn't know a lot of the
big marvel disney plus shows are
actually being run
by former rick and morty staffers one of
the rick and morty writers is doing
marvel's loki show that they're in the
middle of filming with tom hiddleston
right now or at least they're getting
ready to start filming again
that's going to premiere next year one
of the other writers from the pickle
rick episode is also doing marvel's
she-hulk series i don't have a lot of
news about that yet they haven't said
much about it since they started writing
it
so what will probably happen is is
they'll probably drop a proper rick and
morty season five trailer later this
year sometime in the fall maybe around
october
whatever they wind up releasing of
course i'll do videos for it there's
going to be a bunch more comic con
trailers this weekend so as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see those videos when i post them
while you wait for everything click here
for all my rick and morty season 4
episode videos
and click here for the full opening
scene from marvel's new mutants movie
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight